[Music]
assalamualaikum ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the t3m podcast
with fayad rami and angel and we are
joined with our first ever
guest on this show fletcher why don't
you introduce yourselves
to my name is fletcher um
i know these guys just by through tik
tok and social media i'm a
revert muslim and uh just excited to be
on here
we actually talked about going live like
months ago
yeah yeah so subhanallah
it's about time so welcome podcast
mother
thank you so much
we consider ourselves reverse a certain
extent we were born into a muslim family
but never really practicing
so why don't you tell us
about your journey how you came to islam
and what was like in the beginning
yeah i'll talk a little bit in brief i
actually have a full like 20 minute
youtube video where i kind of go over
this
but in brief i uh
um i grew up in a protestant christian
household
uh i wouldn't say we were very
practicing at all it was more just
you know we went to church on christmas
we'd go you know
every month or so you know we
we celebrated christmas and easter and
you know the holidays but
um i was never really connected with
this idea of you know
either a triune god like i was never
really a part of my church
um i never really uh you know connected
with the youth
i would come i'd go on youth trips and
uh you know mission trips and such but
i never really um connected with the
faith
uh i discovered islam when i actually
went to a
christian church camp it was back in
like when i was like 16 or 15 or
something like that where our topic
for the church camp was like world
religions and like
uh like how does how does how us as
christians can like
be with our non-christian neighbors
and during that time i like i fell in
love with this idea of learning about
these different religions
and not just islam like islam was one of
the topics there was judaism buddhism
and
i think hinduism and i
when i went when i got back home it was
just like
i really enjoyed studying these
different religions you know comparing
it to mine
and so i started my own journey of like
okay i'm going to study these religions
because i really enjoy them and the
first one i'm going to go with
is islam no reason at all i don't know
why father of allah but i chose this
first and it was about a nine month
process before i took my shahada
of just self research and my own study
i didn't have any help with any muslims
i didn't know any muslims i didn't know
there was any in my
area until i don't know how many months
in but
we had this like interfaith
peace walk almost where my church and
the local masjid we got together and we
just kind of
uh we walked from like one building to
the other and it was about like a three
mile walk or whatever
and that was the first time i ever met a
muslim and it was an amazing experience
and i got invited to ramadan and i
experienced
[Music]
you know spending the night in the
masjid it was pretty amazing
and then you know nine months after
wherever this all happened
i would have been 17 at the time
i then took my shahada uh and
my parents were there with me they've
been supportive all throughout the whole
way and still alhamdulillah
you know my law guide them to islam um
and yeah i mean you know two years later
after that shahadah i'm here now
alhamdulillah
allah so how old are you now then i'm 19
right now
19 masha'allah man i thought you were a
lot older
wonderful story man
so how would you say you've grown in the
last two years
i'd say have grown like a lot
from i mean like those first
during that nine month period i learned
a lot about islam like so much so
that when i took my shahada uh
the brothers who helped me out like like
they taught me how to make
and they were like okay let's go pray
and like i just kind of walked right
into it and you kind of knew everything
like how to
how to praise the law like i knew
exactly what to say but then it just
those first few months were just kind of
like the exact same thing
and then just it drastically took off i
would say
by the next ramadan by the next ramadan
my first ramadan i'd say as a muslim is
when it really took off when i really
decided
you know i really love this religion i
really want to study it in depth
and it's just blown up every sense you
know
reading and studying and memorizing
alhamdulillah you know i really can't
explain it
in like words masha allah and that's i
mean that's the best kind of feeling the
best kind of experience to have
that way you can't even find the words
to explain because at that point
you know what's beyond anything normal
right that's when it becomes you know
something from the divine
that's what miracles are right they're
unexplainable anomalies
so one thing i've been wondering before
i let one of the brothers take over one
thing i was wondering
what specifically are you studying
because there are many sciences in islam
right you're either you know you study
hadith
you have to take one venture and you can
spend an entire lifetime studying that
and you may not even
come close to completing it even though
nobody really completes it
so what are you studying specifically
i guess it's i guess i'm not really
studying one thing in particular
when we look at the pious predecessors
they studied all of these things in
depth
equally uh but i would say
but if they had to choose you know if
any of the prize predecessors had to
choose one thing to study
they would choose the seerah you know
the life of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
um that's probably been the most thing
i've been studying
is you know the life of muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi and you know how he lived and uh
and in in that comes hadith and it comes
50 rulings and it comes
and it comes all of these things in the
tafsir of the quran and the quran itself
you know
the seerah really encompasses every
islamic science
in a basic format that's easy to
understand
and that's what i would recommend to
anyone who wants to like study islam is
to study the sierra
that's the best thing and it's the
foundation you need
for studying everything else
perfect subhanallah it's actually
amazing because last episode
we were talking about the history of
islam yeah that would have been amazing
if we had one
and you could have made a lecture
in sha allah you guys have been awfully
quiet
today you guys have any questions i am
listening i'm just taking it in man
all right pause
all right it's been a lot
all right one i feel like everybody has
that one moment
in their journey to islam where it just
hits you know what i'm talking about
right like yeah
can you recall a specific moment when it
just hit you
yeah i i can't ex i can't pick out a
specific time when it happened but i
know like when it happened
uh so i think so in my journey to islam
in my studies to islam
uh i would say like the quran
yeah like when you hear a lot of revert
stories it's always like oh the quran
spoke to me you know i understood it
completely you know that's what brought
me to islam
that was never really a big deal for me
i didn't fully understand this
i would say like you know so many months
after i
converted i eventually that concept of
the idea
that the quran is you know the word of
allah you know the uncreated word of
allah
that was the moment that absolutely hit
me and i was just like this religion is
perfect
you know i all my doubts left the window
and they haven't been back since
subhanallah yeah that that would that's
my like one moment that i'm like
i feel like that's something a lot of
people unfortunately lack today
realizing how much of a blessing the
quran is
and how much of a mercy it is from allah
because if you just think about it
right if if we if people were born
knowing that the quran is the unchanged
words of allah
the one who created them their family
the universe their
in existence if they just if they just
knew that
i don't think they'd pick up a book
besides the quran if they were born with
that kind of understanding
like how could a muslim
know or live life hearing that this is
the book of the one who created them
like the allah created you and he
created this
not created is uncreated but in the
sense that he revealed it
yeah and you don't take time to read it
subhanallah it's like people don't value
or appreciate
the quran at all and it's it's really
unfortunate
yeah but would you have any tips then
for connecting with the quran or
starting to connect with the quran
i i mean that's the first thing is just
to read it you know
the prophet i sent him when revelation
was revealed to him
he was told by angels you know read
read in the name of your lord i mean
that's that's what you should do you
should just try to read the quran and if
you can't read it in arabic
try to read the best translation you can
find and if you
and i would recommend try to learn the
arabic to read it it's extremely
beneficial
another thing i would say is to learn if
you were in doubt about the quran
learn how it was preserved learn how it
was kept intact i would say
like that was one of the main things
that really like kind of reinforced it's
like
there's no way possible that this
perfect
text you know with zero contradictions
and uh
you know even to the even to the
extremely poetic arabs at the time this
was
extremely above them impossible to
replicate just to learn how it's
preserved and
i wouldn't say created but how how the
arabs at the time perceived it
uh from muhammad said that is like a
beauty in itself
just the uh linguistic linguistic
finesse of the quran
i think that's pretty dope man and i'm
gonna add to it man i'm gonna piggyback
like romney says i'm gonna pay you back
and it's not just
the quran as well like i think that's a
vital vital part
but it's a lot like let's be honest
how many muslims are born muslim
and they just it takes a lot for granted
like they'll try to go through it as
fast as possible or they'll miss it and
they'll be like
i'll just i'll do it next time or i'll
make sure to do it tomorrow or something
like that
or it's like they do select but they're
so absent-minded while they're doing
saliva that they're not actually
connecting and feeling something else
they're just kind of going through the
motions
i think that's a big thing to take into
consideration
here yeah subhanallah fletcher why don't
you tell us what the prophet salallahu
said about
prayer and belief slash disbelief
like what
i guess there's a lot you could say
that's right i was referring to a
specific hadith
um i don't know if i know that hadith
die of time
um as far as you know the process i sent
allah said that the the bridge
between belief and disbelief is
abandoning
is leaving your prayer so what does that
say about people
who are one you know they don't have the
don't have the
focus in prayer to those who are a
little
fumble you know fumbling with their
prayers and stuff or three those who
actually left their prayer
or don't you know try and commit
themselves to making it on time
the bridge they're on the bridge they're
crossing the bridge to disbelief
in abandoning the act itself and
subhanallah one thing i want to say is
one when i went through you know what i
went through a few years ago
one thing i was told one thing people
are usually told is like oh you know
they don't need you you're better off
and whatever right and they make it like
about
them losing you right not you losing
them
and it's kind of like a lot of people
think i don't pray because i don't want
to
right whatever i don't want to and i'm i
get to spend my time doing something
else
but i think a more truthful way to look
at it would be
allah did not bless you with the ability
or the want to pray because praying in
and of itself is such a beautiful and
beneficial thing
to the mind body and soul literally all
three
so if allah doesn't put in somebody's
heart the desire to pray
that is a curse that is not something
that is good and it's not even
at that point it may not even be you
who's deciding i don't want to pray
it's allah who has not blessed you with
the blessing of prayer in your life
and only when you change what's in
yourself allah will change you
or allah will change your situation
because allah says that he does not
change the situation of a person or a
people
until they change what's in themselves
subhanallah
well it's like what fire said where it's
like you take one step toward
a lot and he takes what a hundred what
you say bro
allah literally says my slave if you if
you walk to me i run to you
if you come to me at hands like they
come to you at arm's length and there's
times in my life where i feel like
i'm not as good of a muslim as i should
be and i'm not putting as much towards
my
my dean and my man as i should but allah
is always over delivering
like it's it's almost like allah doesn't
owe me anything but if i give a little
if i pray on time if i do this
i realize the values are immense and
it's like it's insane
and when i don't it's like i don't even
get that much consequences but that just
reinforces why i should be praying
more and like staying on track staying
on top of everything and then when i do
a lot and i feel like i'm going above
and beyond
and doing what i feel like is a good
example oh man then it's like
allah is over delivered to the next
level
absolutely i feel like there's so much
in islam
that you could do for allah to bless and
increase you because allah says in the
quran
if you were just grateful if you're just
grateful i will increase you
and it's kind of like how hard is it to
be grateful
how about heart island is real hard bro
apparently
and you know what it's funny because um
i believe in in surah salah i may be
mistaken but
in the quran allah talks about how
shaytaan
you know when it is when he became
shaytan and what happened with that
story
he said his sin was arrogance right and
everything i'm saying i took from nouman
ali khan just to give you know respect
there but
his sin was arrogance right i'm better
than adam
i don't want to prostrate him and he
disobeyed allah because of that
but he didn't say to allah i'm going to
show you that they're also arrogant he
said i'm going to show you that they're
ungrateful
and i think that's something that's
amazing because the opposite he's
basically saying that the opposite of
arrogance
is not being humble it's being grateful
and i was thinking about it subhan allah
if you look at everything you have
even your what's what what's in your
what's inside yourself what's outside
everything together if you look at it
and you say all of this is because of
allah
not because of me that's being grateful
but it doesn't leave any room for
arrogance after that what do you have to
be arrogant if you say everything good i
have is from allah
what's left for you to be arrogant about
because arrogance come from comes from
the sent that
i'm better if you're saying everything i
have is because of allah then allah is
better you're not
subhanallah man that's hard hitting that
hidden
time i heard that so
touching briefly on the topic of salah
when you guys brought it up
i have a question for all three of you
so you can answer one at a time
but to you specifically individually
why do you think people don't take salat
seriously
and what makes you prioritize that and
not neglect that
you want me to go in first there you go
so i think the reason why people
don't take it seriously is because they
haven't been fully fully present
at least one time because if you're
fully present at least one time bro like
well you don't know you don't know
what's gonna happen like well the other
day
i was praying isha and subhanallah bro i
was so present while i was doing this
prayer that as i was reciting but i just
started crying
like what what in what would have made
me cry about like what would make
anyone cry in a situation like that
you're just reciting something that you
memorize
and you're over here praying but you're
so present
and you're so in tune with the salah
with the prayer
that you're experiencing something else
and i think that's that's
a huge reason why people you know take
it for granted bro
i felt that man that's really
um i would say a reason why people
abandon their salah or delay their salah
or
don't have that full focus on their
salah is
um is they don't have full taqwa
of allah they don't have that full
uh allah consciousness you know
you know salah is literally you
prostrating
and bowing to your creator to allah
himself i mean that's
you know we don't we don't physically
see a law we don't say allah is
literally staying in front of us but
that is the emotion
as if he was and that if
people can really get that through their
head and i'm talking to myself as well
if people can relate to their head
that's you know
this is a law in front of you you know
after your
law you could die in the middle of your
salah you could die you know allah is
the creator of
everything and the sustainer of
everything and that to have that full
to have full understanding and talk of a
lot is extremely powerful and that's
exactly what um
i had said um to have that you'll get
that you get that true experience
and that you won't ever not have that
true experience again
because you need to have that first true
experience
to briefly briefly i guess answer the
question
i feel like any time somebody takes
something for granted
or doesn't fulfill the needs or the
requirements of it
it's because they don't understand the
value of it
and this can go for anything in life
like let's say your car needs
you know a tune-up or to be fixed or
something and you just never fix the
cars because you don't really care about
the car right you don't you don't think
about how it gets you
here and there every day right how it
drives you around now if there's an
emergency you need to get someone to the
hospital
um you jump in you go to the hospital
right
you don't think about how how necessary
it is in your life so
when it comes to salah and people
abandoning it it's because they don't
value it
they don't value it and for them to be
able to evaluate they have to understand
salah and to understand salah they have
to understand allah and their place in
the universe
their place is a human being that allah
created us in a very specific way
and that he tells us what's best for us
and if we and if allah makes something
obligatory
like you must do it that is serious the
one who created you that knows
everything
with no bias at all he just knows what's
best
he says this is obligatory you must do
this and then you say
no i don't think i will it's kind of
like are you dumb
like what has to go through somebody's
head but i don't think they have that
thought process it's more of like it's
laziness
it's i don't i don't really think about
it it doesn't cross my mind or
you know they don't want to think about
it because when they think about it they
feel bad and they don't want to feel bad
so
i would say you know it everything in
life either starts to appear or
starts in here what i'm putting on my
heart but and
if you don't if you don't internalize it
with the proper intention because allah
says in the quran every action is by its
intention if you don't have the proper
intention the action is not going to
line up
and even if you the action does line up
you're not going to get rewarded for it
because you're not right in here
so people have to make sure this is
straight and their heart is straight
on the straight path before they
actually you know
introduce islam properly into their life
and actually build a proper
proper connection with allah in the
sense that they're now acting in the way
that allah would want them to act
fire would you say is it in your opinion
why people take salah for granted yeah
well
why aren't you speaking in in your
tongue bro and your experience is like
because you probably you probably have
haven't you i think we all have at some
point
yeah i'm only going to speak on behalf
of myself but i feel like a lot of
brothers and sisters who
were in the predicament that i was in
can relate to that
and it's no shade at my parents or any
other parents or anyone
but i feel like parents prematurely
over emphasize halal and haram
without emphasizing and properly forming
a foundation
for iman and islam
and this often causes kids to be
confused and
feeling like ah it's like a chore like
you keep telling a kid okay
eat this don't eat that do this don't do
that
um you know act like this don't act like
that oh it's friday we got to do this
instead of that
instead of understanding the value
behind it so a kid goes into this
autonomous
state of it's not like submission but
almost like compliance because you kind
of have to do with
what your parents tell you and you get
value from it
but you don't realize why the value is
and where it's coming from so for
example
as a kid yeah i always prayed five times
a day but only because my parents told
me to i did i got good grades i was
doing well in life
but it was like i didn't understand it
was linked to that
i probably took it for granted i thought
it was circumstantial i thought it was
it was just me whatever and i got kind
of it wasn't humility
it wasn't understanding the place in the
universe as a human being like
brother rami mentioned and
compare that conversely to someone who
understands why they're doing what
they're doing
why they're praying why behind
everything
it makes it so much easier to understand
the importance and value behind salah
behind prayer
so for me it was almost and that's the
same with just
quran praying fasting i did these only
because i had to
but then when i was in a position where
i didn't have to i took these for
granted and i was like okay
they were always kind of optional to me
in terms of seeing value
so now i don't have to do it and that's
when i really noticed okay when i stop
doing these things
ah this is where the missing piece was
when i stopped doing this
it kind of backfired i didn't fast i
didn't pray
um you know eating haram doing this that
and the other
and it's like okay now i kind of see why
i had to do it which was good
subhanallah my parents
you know 100 got it right where they
told me
you know here's what to do and they put
me in the right path but
i couldn't form that association between
um why we're doing it
and the results i would be getting in
life
subhanallah man it's like you said bro
take a step towards me
i'll run towards you
[Music]
man i would i would add to that and
say that when we look at the life of the
prophet saddam
and his sahaba his companions
when we look at the meccan period when
he first started out
you know there were no there were barely
any obligations there was
very much little
beginning in the meccan period there was
no you know alcohol prohibition there
was no
there was no five daily salah yet there
was no
there's various little other things and
that
those first sahabahs in the period
they were founded on belief first and
then
like they were founded on who is the law
and who is your messenger and that once
they finally got that once everyone got
that idea of who is allah and who's
their messenger
then he then allah sent down
you should not eat this you should not
drink this
uh you know here's your five day list of
law
and it has been made easy for you uh
subhanallah i mean the exact the
opposite of what you said that
when we raise kids is what i would say
is that you need to focus on
because you have that room before
obligation is upon them you know
boys and girls don't have to pray tell
their so-and-so age
you don't have to fast other so-and-so
age that you should focus on
teaching him who is the law and his
[Music]
okay i'll take that as a science okay he
he got married what was it a few months
back
this brother may allah bless him just
take him to your account he's 19.
he's married he's studying islam he
looks amazing
man prime example prime example man
we can do it
yeah yeah this is i want this to be a
message to everybody man
look at our brother here fletcher not to
you know to his horn because probably
seven said avoid praising people too
much so i'm not gonna do that
i may i may insult you a little bit
afterwards just to bring you back down
but um man he's 19 he's studying islam
he just reverted two years ago
he's married masha allah already how's
it going
yo fletcher i got a question for you
brother yeah what would you what would
advice
would you give to people who whether
they're reverts or whether they're born
muslims who
or let's say they are your age well
let's say they might be a little bit
younger or a little bit older
and they're not married yet like bro
when when a man is not married to a
woman
and he is not performing the natural
obligation
you guys know what happens you guys know
the things that goes on inside of our
heads
i the advice i'd give is what
the advice that also lost i said him and
gave that um
he said oh young men if you're able to
support a wife get married
and that it has been made so
in a way it's been made harder in a way
that it's been made easy for us nowadays
that i would say it's
harder to look for a wife because of or
a husband
because of just or the society we live
in and the the taboo of getting married
younger
but it's been made easier for us because
money is in abundance you know
alhamdulillah especially where we live
that it is easy to earn money and earn a
living and that
there's really no excuse to not get
married young
nowadays now if you don't want to that's
fine
but some some brothers should get
married
some brothers should get married sooner
than others just because of
natural obligations as you put it um
to protect from the shaitaan i would say
getting married is an important thing
and that you really
you shouldn't i would say it's important
to be picky
don't be over picky you there's a
there's a
i don't know if it was a hadith or if a
sahaba narrated it
um where a man was asking you know i'm
looking for a wife who is
you know the way he described is like
this much beauty and she has this much
wealth and
her family is this is this good and
you know such and so such the absolute
perfect woman and the sahaba
narrated to him you know or said to him
you know it's like i know where to find
that woman for you and
and the person was like where is she and
he's like and jenna you know of course
it's like you can't you shouldn't be too
picky
about it you know may allah make it easy
for all the brothers looking for a wife
a little man
shouldn't be too picky but still gotta
have standards right
yeah absolutely and the standard should
be
yeah as the prophet saddam said you know
you should look for a pious wife first
you know if
out of all the standards money wealth
beauty and family lineage you should
look for piety first and i would say
that is the most important thing i mean
if you're going to look
that is the most important thing
just just to pay you back off that point
the process it's amazing because he
didn't
completely omit or forget about the fact
that people marry for beauty for status
for lineage for wealth
he didn't say like people don't do that
he said people will get married for
those reasons
right and he included character in deen
and he said if you want to be from the
winners if you want to be a winner mary
for character and deen
subhan allah and that's that's
essentially it have standards make it
make the first of standards you're
the the person's character in dean and
then i would say i'm not married so i
don't really know but i would say after
that
compatibility is really important i
heard that the scholars were in depth on
how important it is to be compatible
and then after that whatever you want
just don't be too picky
but uh bless you you said something that
really stuck out to me you said that
it's a lot easier financially in the
west
where we live first i want to ask where
do you live if you don't mind me asking
i live in uh i live in the united states
i live in arkansas
okay marshall boy
[Music]
i was always wondering why isn't it not
pronounced our kansas
i can't i can't be the only one yeah man
go for it lily every single person that
lives
outside of arkansas calls arkansas or
kansas
and the reason why is because um
the native americans that lived in the
area that is now called arkansas
they they also called it arkansas they
called it arkansas
and they spelled it a-r-k-a-n-s-a-w how
it's pronounced
and the colonizers the invaders they
came and they took this land but
they really liked the name arkansas but
for some reason
they spelt it our kansas but some people
will say
some people say what about kansas wasn't
kansas kansas was founded after arkansas
so technically
kansas should be pronounced console
dude you're the first person i've ever
met from arkansas
arkansas yeah there you go
i was about to say oh kansas but i
corrected myself that's good
all right um wait hold on hold on i got
a question i got a question
so how baby you said you got married
how long ago has it been a month two
months it's been
about two months two months bro
so would you say your roster's full or
you are doing tryouts in the near future
i'm going to skip that question just
case my life right now
these are the fifth amendment all right
in america
that's fair um all right
thank you i got a question real quick
okay um so when people come into islam
they they're new into it they're
introduced into it
and they overcome this concept of you
know the six pillars of iman
and the five pillars of islam let's talk
about that let's talk about the six
pillars of
iman um ntu as
a fellow reverb as a brother in islam as
a brother in faith
when you look at it now no doubt about
full conviction
but when you look back at where you were
in the
introductory to islam in your journey
in that nine-month period where you
didn't have guidance and support from
fellow muslims
how did you get through each of the six
and if it wasn't that big of a deal for
you if some were easier
um let's still talk about all six how
would you say that new rebirths and
people looking into islam because we
have a lot of people in the
in the inbox and the dms and you know a
lot of people i i
usually always have a problem with the
first um pillar of iman which is just
believing in god
but if you guys watch the first video um
go back to t3m e1 you shouldn't have a
problem with that but let's talk about
all six of them anyway
in your opinion how can they navigate
through them how can they
not just have blind faith or accept any
um because that's not really the proper
way
how can they actually fully form that
conviction without sex
yeah i guess i guess we can skip that
the first belief
because i'll show you guys i i went
through i went through all three of your
videos or was it four now
of um i didn't go through i i
who's the brother that keeps posting the
time stamps i kept going through each of
those
masha'allah um
so belief in allah i mean it's
it's the natural fitrah that allows the
belief in the law and now you guys
covered that very good one shallow but
uh when it comes to
i was it belief in allah belief in the
angels belief in the books belief in the
prophets
uh belief in uh i think the goddard and
the decree of
allah and i believe the belief in the
day of judgment
yeah the day of judgment that's what it
was yeah and let's talk about all those
yeah so if we go through it one at a
time belief in the angels
after the belief in allah i
i guess i don't really know how to
really kind of go through this
in a way that's just you know if you
believe in allah
and you like if you if you have full
conviction of allah
and that if he tells you that how the
angels were created
and how they work you should have no
problem believing in the angels if you
already believe in allah
i don't know and i i guess that's kind
of how all of them go down
if you really if you really have that
first pillar you should have no problem
with the rest
um but you know certain cases arise um
fully admit yeah i would say brother not
to interrupt you at all but
in terms of the first pillar once people
get a lot i think that's the most
important thing believing in the oneness
and unicity of allah
and um you know omni omnipresent omni
whatever everything the whole
nine the first one is the most important
but i think another pivotal one
not equal in measure but definitely in
value is belief
in the authenticity of the quran and
that it is the literal word of god
because if they can believe that the
quran is the literal word of allah
how are you going to have a problem with
the angels um the day of judgement and
all those because all of them come from
the quran
if you look at the quran and you're like
okay i'm kind of skeptical
you know maybe maybe it wasn't um actual
word of god
you have a lot of religions that are
man-made today so i don't blame them
um they're looking at books that were
made by man so
anyone that's looking at that i feel
like that's an important keystone
it's an important turning stone so how
do you think people should navigate that
i know you touched a little bit about
look at the
authenticity and preservation of the
quran why don't you get into that
yeah i would say yeah if you believe in
allah you believe in this quran
everything else falls under that if you
have full conviction of both of course
um yeah when we when we look at the
quran
it's you have to look at it from
not only the context it was revealed in
but
how it was preserved over time and
and just like the the linguistic finesse
of it like how
it is spoken and how it is um almost
like
almost sung you could say but sung in
like a poetic way
and that just
the you know some people say like like
the scientific miracles any of the
miracles the historical miracles the
crown are good proofs for the quran
to show that it is out of this world
literally um
and that
trying to think what was like the thing
for me that i keep forgetting with like
the thing for me was
uh it's just like
i'm trying to think i can't think of it
i don't know
thank you man there's no pressure if any
of um the other brothers rami or brother
angel
want to chime in what was it about the
quran that
gave you unequivocal doubt that this is
the literal word of allah for me
i'm a little more like i'm in grad
school right now
i love science so for me it was the most
secular aspects of it
like the prophecies in the quran the
scientific miracles like you brought up
these are things you cannot make up
ladies and gentlemen fourteen hundred
years ago
let alone from a man who couldn't read
or write from a man who didn't go to
educational institutions like we have
today masha'allah there was no internet
there was there was nothing there was no
telescopes there was no microscopes and
i'm just saying that because it goes
from like microbiology and cell biology
to like astronomy
it's insane subhanallah and when you
look at things like that you can't
really
it takes more faith to believe that a
man just made these claims
and pulled it out of thin air than to
just believe that
okay it had to be some some divinity
some divine aspect to it but that's just
me
um i'll let you two go on on before
fletcher takes over again
what was it for you so
bro i think it's crazy romney i'm gonna
go first here because
you took too long bro i was gonna say i
want hill to go first because it was
more recent for him
okay okay okay okay we'll go first i
will go first
uh but yeah i think it's crazy man like
some people actually choose to believe
that the prophet peace be upon him was
crazy
and that he was just like basically like
what you were compared to a
schizophrenic person where they're
hearing voices but i'm like
are you serious like you that's
that's jahi bro if someone says that's
ja here because like they haven't
really gone in depth into the studies
and actually
looked into his life and adis and all
that it's like bro like
if you really look at it it's like nah
bro this this guy was not
you know schizophrenic or something like
that
you know but to get back to the main
point here
you gotta ask like what was uh what
makes the quran
uh repeat the question again
what was it specifically about the quran
individually right this is just for you
yes yeah that made it
unequivocally undoubtedly the word of
allah the literal word of god yeah so
not made by some man
it's simplicity is is very simple
it's a it's literally the instruction
manual and
it's probably like we talked about you
get a bed frame from ikea you want the
instruction manual to be as simple as
clear as precise and concise
as possible if it's telling you to use
this screw
in this position right here and then use
this bracket over here like you want
that to be right you don't want it to be
uh where there's room for interpretation
where it's like yo use this screw here
or then figure out what to use for this
bracket you know you can use it like
this you can flip it over
just have fun be creative with it you
know like and
not to throw any trash on
the bible but man when i was studying it
there was a lot of room for
interpretation and that's that's all i'm
going to say there
yeah not too they mean any other walks
of faith and religions but
what was it about you or what was it for
you that made the
quran compared to any other books of
faith the instruction manual on her
because you say it was an instruction
manual but there's a bible there's a
torah
there's the hindu scriptures there's the
buddhist scriptures
so what was it did i wait did i not um
denied on that did i not answer that
yeah you said it was an instruction
manual i said it's simplicity
and that is it's basically logical and
it's like it's
very simple clear-cut and if you want me
to add anything else i would add that
it's complete
versus like you look at other religions
you look at other cultures and their
beliefs and all that it's like
they have pieces but it's not complete
it's not the entire puzzle
they give you a piece of the puzzle
versus when you come to islam and you
read the quran
it gives you the entire puzzle it
doesn't give you just one piece
that's what i was looking for bro the
all-encompassing nature of
the quran masha allah
rami bro let's hear you
so i can't remember exactly what it was
that made me
you know just look at the quran say okay
for sure
this is the word of allah i actually
don't even remember a time when i
decided that okay now i accept as the
word of allah
it's weird because there's there isn't a
specific time i can pinpoint where i was
like okay
now i believe in it it was kind of like
i was born into a muslim family so
i always knew about it i never really
looked at it so it was kind of like
maybe i started a mile ahead in that in
the sense that
i didn't look at it as anything other
than you know the word of allah
i just didn't really have reason to
believe in it but i just that's what i
was taught
i was like okay cool then i go on to
like the scientific miracles the
linguistic miracles
and the the eloquence of the quran and
as brother fletcher likes to put it the
finesse
masha'allah and
that did help but it wasn't really
proof because there's like
you can have an argument or you can just
have subjectively this is enough for me
right
but the quran what i think is amazing
about the quran is that it gives a
full argument for why it is the word of
allah or how it is true how to know is
true what's testable what's verifiable
what's falsifiable and it gives you even
the tool to interpret it and i would say
this is the best
tool of interpretation for anything in
chapter 3 verse 7 it says this is the
book which we revealed
in it are verses which are clear and the
clear verses are the foundation of the
book
and then allah says in the same verse
and some
other verses are ambiguous those who
look to spread
mischief and doubt rely on the ambiguous
verses
in their false interpretations that's
the literal verse go read it
allah says take the queer verses as the
foundation
and then use those to interpret the
ambiguous ones and if you use ambiguous
ones you're spreading mischief and doubt
because you don't know what you're
talking about
and when you say it's the instruction
manual
not only is it telling you not only is
it an instruction manual on how to live
life
it's an it has an instruction manual on
how to read the instruction manual
we're being spoon fed here man
subhanallah oh man
allah makes it so easy for us
you are right a thousand percent bro and
i'm gonna let fletcher answer the
question if
you know she decided anymore to add to
what he previously mentioned
to the to his answer but after that's
done let's
wrap that up and talk about the next
pillar which is the day of
judgment and i know rami has a lot to
talk about it why there must
necessarily be a day of judgment while
there must be the last day
yeah i would i was listening to all your
guys's points and i still couldn't think
of like what it was but rama you really
put it in words that like i
i couldn't think of that you know this
book
is it's an instruction manual for an
instruction manual or
what is what was the other words you
said like it teaches you how to read its
own book
or it teaches it's a law teaching you
about allah
in the best way and i guess that's that
that's that linguistic-ness i was
talking about is that like
the quran is built so perfectly
in so many different ways whether it's
miracles how it's formatted
how it's spoken how the harakats are
it's built so perfectly that it's
it seems impossible to deny and to see
that
and to see how it spread and to see how
it
has been remembered for thousands of
years
through memorization and
um different ways of saying it it's
it it seems almost impossible that how
could this
book that has been reserved preserved
either in manuscript form
and or um or and memorization form
not have gotten corrupted in all those
times you know
only by the will of allah that that has
not happened and that's the fountain
so i don't i just i guess i can't give a
definite one answer
and uh well off on him
man let me just throw in one last thing
to tie it all together bro
i love that not only is it the
instruction manual of the instruction
manual
but it challenges you it gives you
the challenge it says if you believe
you can conceive something near
what is being said here gather everyone
go ahead
try do your best bro and no one in over
1400 years has been able to do anything
that bro that's beautiful subhanallah
since we talked about it i actually want
to give the
the the full-fledged islamic or quranic
argument
so brother brother fletcher masha allah
he mentioned
the preservation of the quran allah says
that
basically we have revealed the book and
we will preserve it that's a guarantee
that's a promise from allah
everything god says is true therefore if
we find it's been preserved
that's true for imagine creating a book
1400 years ago
in the middle of the desert and at this
point islam didn't spread all over the
world at this point
right but allah is saying or the prophet
muhammad
in from the non-muslim perspective this
man named muhammad sallallahu and i'm in
the desert is saying
we have revealed the book and we will
preserve it and then you find 1400 years
later that promise is true
a bit sketchy right it's not something
that somebody can just
you know make up so okay that's true it
claims to be from allah that is true
and then as brother angel mentioned
bring just if you think you know this
isn't from allah bring just one chapter
like it just one chapter gather
everybody together bring the whole squad
man bring the whole team
make one chapter like it they couldn't
do that the best of poets the best poet
he went and he said to the people like
listen man
this is i this is from allah it is from
allah i can't compete with it
i'm no match i have nothing to say
against it and for 1400 years they
couldn't bring
one chapter one chapter similar to the
quran the shortest chapter in the quran
is what three verses
like 10 words or something and i heard
it uses 31 or so literary devices
including prophecy
all while rhyming and sounding you know
having that beautiful finesse on
masha'allah so check that off
as well and then allah says that if this
is if this book has been from anyone
other than god if it was from anyone
other than god you would have found in
it many contradictions
there is not one single clear
contradiction in the quran but there is
and every other uh scripture on the face
of the earth you could say
as far as we know and yes unfortunately
no disrespect to christians this does
include the bible
when it says that when it says in one
book that there are three people there
and then up in another book about the
same situation that there are only two
people there
that's a contradiction the quran does
not have that
and the quran is not sure it's short
compared to the bible but it's not short
six thousand or so verses subhan allah
and this is the quran argument yeah okay
you're on a roll once you wrap this up
go straight into the day of judgment
insha allah bismillah so on top of this
we have prophecies in the quran
like surah arum which talks about
fletcher it was the romans that were
defeated right
yeah okay yeah the romans were defeated
by the persians
and allah says in three to nine years
they will come back and they will win
and i'm not talking about like a little
like you know
they got hit one more time than the
other side did
like during the street fight i hit him
three times hit me four times he won
it's like they left me unconscious on
the floor kind of thing
right and it's like in in a few days in
a few years and three to nine years in
the quran it says they're gonna come
back
right if someone usually like leaves me
unconscious on the floor you're not
going to think this guy's going to come
back you're going to think that he's
dead probably
right in 39 years they're going to come
back and i believe it was i think it was
six or seven years
they actually came back and they beat
the persians
and he made a bet which isn't a bet
because if allah says something's going
to happen you know what's going to
happen you're not gambling
um he made a bet with with the
non-muslims saying i bet
in in three to nine years they're gonna
come back and then that happened and he
he won that
and on top of it it says on that day the
muslims will rejoice
and the day the romans defeated the
persians the muslims defeated the
non-muslims in the battle of badr and
that was like a double prophecy
in one surah and then you have the
prophecies of the prophet muhammad
you have what people like gandhi and leo
tolstoy wrote about him
it's deep man it's not just like oh i
believe it because i believe it we have
reason to believe it and that's the most
beautiful part
about being a muslim alhamdulillah is
you have reason to be convicted and it's
not blind faith
now talking about the day of judgment so
what was the question exactly if you
could
the question was we brother we were
navigating through the six pillars of
iman because a lot of people have
problems with them and understanding
them so we covered allah
the unicity and the authenticity that
there is only one god
that's allah subhanahu ta allah as we
muslims call it
next we talked about the preservation of
the quran believing quran is the literal
word of god
next one was believing that the prophet
sallallahu islam was the final messenger
of allah
we can't have no problems with these
because how could we have islam
about the prophet and so on and all the
miracles all the prophecies
and last episode we studied his life or
a couple episodes ago for you guys
but with that all being said and done
next one
was going to be how do people believe in
their judgment
and that kind of ties into heaven and
hell because all of these are things we
can't see
yeah there's claims in the book in the
quran about
the day of judgment but for anyone
that's not using that
as the main thing to revolve around
all right well i mean you could this is
not going to be like a full deductive
argument using objective premises
because
some people don't even believe in
morality they don't believe in justice
and that that is what it is and even if
they do believe it that's the subjective
thing still
but if you're a person who believes that
you know there should be some kind of
justice or there has to be some kind of
you know just order or something then
you have to believe the day of judgment
or something equivalent to it
because let's say there is a man who
kills a hundred people
the worst you can do is kill him one
time
there are still the 99 other people that
were taken there are still the families
that are suffering for the rest of their
lives because of what this person did
so it's not it's not fair it's never
going to be fair you're never going to
have perfect justice in this world and
even if you try your absolute hardest
i think one scholar once you have said
that let's say somebody slaps me and i
slap him back
how do i know my slap didn't hurt him
more than it has hurt me
you're not going to have that fair
justice that
that pure fair justice in this life
you're not going to have that so if
you're a person who believes
you know things should be made right and
you believe in allah or god you believe
because we already went through a belief
in one god
if you believe that this one god is
going to make things right you would
have to believe in the day of judgment
or something equivalent to it because
how else is allah going to make things
fair and just
if he doesn't bring us all together in a
giant courtroom on one
day called the day of judgment after
everything is done and he says you have
your deeds here you have your
the evidence is here right we have seen
the evidence we have seen the evidence
and muhammad reference if you guys know
you know if not then
i feel sorry for you i'm just playing
but for real
you have the evidence right this is what
you did on this date it's what you did
at this time
and some people are going to be you know
put on the spot like you did this this
this is that
and some people will receive the books
in the right hand they'll be happy some
people will receive the books in the
left
hand they will not be happy and if you
believe in fairness and justice then
that is the day
that people also call the day of
recompense right you will be recompensed
for what you did
so that's the necessity the moral
necessity of the day of judgment in
islam
let me add something to that bro yeah
for those of you that
don't know and for those of you that do
know serbs is a good reminder and
refresher
always bro your literal eyes your hand
your nose your ears are going to testify
for or against you
is that not insane it's crazy because
i think i'm going to skip on this topic
i'm not i'm be honest i'm not too
knowledgeable on this and i don't want
to
say something that is wrong i'm having a
favor
i mean the only thing that i would add
the only thing that i would say
is not really for the believers i mean i
guess it could be as well for like
those that say they're believers but
they're not like 100
in it but like let's say you're a
non-believer
right like it's always your choice
whether you're gonna believe
or whether you're not gonna believe like
there's no evidence that this proves god
but like scientifically speaking there's
no evidence that proves god
as of yet you know as of yet but here's
the thing it's always in your
hands like you're the one that's
deciding whether you're going to believe
whether you're not going to believe
and like dude like it's like that saying
goes when we heard as a kid like better
safe than sorry
you know like dude what if
you believe oh no this isn't real this
isn't true
there's no such thing as a day of
judgment and then the day of judgment
comes bro
you imagine that it's kind of law
just to if you're done just to piggyback
off the point there's no
you're not going to have scientific
proof for or against god
um you could look at it like
scientifically what we've observed that
is that um
intelligent design only comes from
intelligence that's what we've observed
for example a painting is not going to
come from like a tree it doesn't have
intelligence
right it's going to come from a human
who has intelligent uh
who has intelligence and has the ability
creative capabilities
and if you look at everything in life
right the organisms the dna
uh everything right it's they call it
the um i think the watchmaker
uh argument or something like that where
it's like you're not gonna find a watch
that's telling the time made from like
nature or something like that
because intelligent design only comes
from intelligence and you could use that
as an argument for okay there's an
intelligent creator
but that's the farthest it's gonna go
but you're never gonna have anything
that disproves god
scientifically because you can't the way
science is done is based on observation
you can't observe god you can only
observe what he has done and over and
then you've already
assumed that he did it so you can't use
science in that sense but there are
philosophical arguments
like we if you go back to the very first
episode we talked about it you can't
have an infinite regression therefore
it's one start therefore the start must
have these necessities
these um necessary attributes
which goes to the quran because allah
says
chapter 112 i always say 111 112 of the
quran
says allah the one allah the
self-sufficient
he does not beget nor is he begotten and
there's nothing comparable to him
that's the description of this
philosophical necessary existence that
we describe so there are reasons to
believe in it
and we always say using the fine tuning
of the universe which is intelligent
design
the dna of every organism that exists in
all the life in the intelligent design
of these things
intelligent design using the
philosophical argument that there must
be a necessary existence
it takes more faith and include in that
islam the quran
it takes more faith to disbelieve in
islam
it takes more faith to disbelieve in a
god it takes more faith to disbelieve in
a creator
than to believe in one that's what i
want new age atheists and people to
understand it takes more faith
to say that okay even though it's
basically impossible that the universe
comes from nothing but it's perfect
in the sense that it's in the way it is
today even though it's basically
impossible i'm gonna take my gamble
even though we've never observed
anything from nature create an
intelligent design and i am
intelligently designed
even though it's impossible from what we
can observe
i'm going to take that gamble yo these
new age atheists be having more blind
faith than us
take that in yeah they believe in a man
and his theory his mechanism
darwinism that existed centuries ago
and he himself said if gradualism fails
gradualism like natural selection over
time if it fails his theory fails and
now they're finding gradualism fails
and they still choose to believe in it
but that's another point that's another
one that's that's not that's that's not
for today
yeah yeah dude i was gonna say like i
highly doubt there's gonna be atheists
that are
this deep into our podcast right now
yeah that's right yeah
bro but to like to finish off what
you're saying here
um this example that i had read someone
wrote this
so you know jessica here so then
well they had said like imagine the dude
who created the sims game
you guys know that game right the sims
where it's like you have the people and
all this stuff it's like basically a
life
in this like video game i imagine the
person who created the sims
they will be the creator of the sims
right and then it's like the sims
trying to understand and trying to prove
the creator and trying to prove how it's
all the stimulation how it's all the
game and everything they're trying to
like
basically get the facts and like
basically show like ah look this is what
the creator is this is how the creator
looks like how are they gonna figure out
how the creator looks like
there's no way that they can figure out
who the creator of the sims game
actually looks like who he is and what
he does and all this stuff
so it's like bro it's it's
it makes you feel a little bro makes you
feel very little
and it's very easy brother to like
operate at that first level and i'm
talking to the cpus in the sims game
right now
the whole algorithm the whole coding all
those characters in the same game to
just do their part
if they're a bad guy in the video game
be the bad guy the good guy cool act
like you got free will go through the
levels
but then there's levels to this because
level two is kind of wondering okay
it's all existential philosophical type
of thing where where am i going with
this why am i in this video game
what's the bigger picture level three is
like next level it's like okay cool
now i'm kind of believing like okay
there's more than this just like angel
said in the other podcast
this dunya he compared it to a matrix in
the sense that the akhirah
the hereafter that's the real thing
that's the real deal the seven heavens
this is just
a glitch not a glitch but just just a
little blip in the whole big picture
yeah stimulation
100 bro so ladies and gentlemen if
you've made it this far
you have no reason to not believe in god
you have no reason to not believe in
the rasool allah the messenger prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
always to be the final slave and
messenger of allah
you have no reason to not believe in the
quran no reason to not believe in the
day of judgment
let's talk about angels man like i don't
know what i'm going to do
before you go into it real quick i want
to sum it up
real quick but
how are we going to have the quran
without the angels
you look at allah talking about how
angels would travel from
this place to another place and he gives
you the distance and then
physicists and cosmologists converted
that today and that turned out to be the
speed of light
subhanallah 1400 years ago there's no
way
and i know man what were you going to
say
it's probably not bro it's amazing
though
but um what you said about like you have
the cpu characters
who like let's say they're bad guys
they're a good guy like all right
they're just gonna do that
right and like that could be basically
referred to as
autopilot right and then the next stage
is like
it's bro when you realize like ah
there's something else there is a
creator you don't know exactly what it
is but you
know you have that inner belief that
feeling inside you
and then the third stage would be
what it is now being an islam being a
muslim
and actually following the instruction
manual of the instruction manual
you know and i don't know man i'm not
going to keep going but
you get what i'm trying to say bro you
good man uh ramirez do you guys have
anything to talk about in terms of
um angels and then the last one would be
the qatar
the decree of allah once we wrap that up
and i hear your word i'm trying to go on
to the next part because we got fletcher
in this right now
i'm trying to get his point on all these
people that are wondering okay
i listen to you guys i'm kind of on
board with it
what about family what about people how
are they gonna look at me
how do i actually convert do i need to
grow a beard um do i need to
learn arabic do i need to now memorize
surahs from the quran
how is this process even done do i need
to go to masjid like what if people see
me
so we'll talk about all that all right
i do have something to add about um the
last
two parts of the man unless brother
fletcher has something to say first no
go ahead
okay i just want to say about everything
that comes after belief in allah
meaning the belief in the messengers and
prophets the books like the revelation
um the angels the day of judgment all of
that stuff
those can only come if you believe in
the quran being the word of allah
which you if you believe the six pillars
of iman and the quran 100
you're that's all you need to be a
muslim if you don't believe in any of
those things
then even if it's just one then you're
not a muslim but
if you believe in the quran you have no
reason to doubt the angels the books
messengers dave judgment
because it's all in the quran so i would
say if a person wants to believe
if they're struggling to believe any of
those they must first find full
conviction in the quran being the word
of allah
and that you go to the miracles of the
quran so this the stage
the stages i see people going through is
belief in one god alone
once they find that belief in the quran
being the word of god and once they
believe the quran is the word of god
the other five pillars of iman after
belief in allah being one
they will all come naturally because you
can't believe the quran
if you don't believe in those things so
those will come out
so you can't prove angels exist
other than using the quran you can't
prove the day of judgment is going to
happen other than using the quran
so it would be almost useless talking
about what's unseen
fletcher what are your thoughts on that
yeah i would say pretty much the like
exact same thing as that i mean
to have belief in everything else up to
this point and not believe in the angels
and we'll get to that called the rule on
a second and not to believe in the
angels is
uh is ignorance it's not
it's giant it's not wanting to fully
submit to a thing you already believe in
which is which seems like illogical of
why anyone
or how anyone could even do that in the
first place and
that was a i i never thought about the
point that i had said
um like how can you not believe in the
angels but believe in the quran and
believe in rasulallah
uh when jibreel is a direct um
you know translation between the two
yeah absolutely
i think that's a very good point in
trying to reconcile everything all
together in one
just like look at man um introduce us to
the topic
imma let you take the floor right now
fletcher for the color of allah people
are wondering what is this decree what
is
do we have free will do we not we kind
of addressed it but
i want your take on it yeah so
what i can in brief say what the quality
of allah is
is if you translate it called the
law is like predestination uh like what
what allah has already decreed for us to
happen meaning that
uh whatever i have already done
allah has already willed it to happen
allah has already allowed it to happen
and what i do in the future is unknown
to me
but allah already knows and has already
decided for it what it to mean
now this some people might say like well
do i have any free will at this point
um it's it's kind of hard to like
fully get the grasp of what actually
free will is and that
i would say like and i i i take this
example from
hashem i really like listening to dr
hatham hajj is where he
says he uses this example that
i have enough free will to say i'm going
to pick up my phone on the table that
you cannot see right now inshallah
i picked up the phone it's in my hand
right now i'm going to put it down
on my table again inshallah and that you
have that much free will
to decide what you're going to do and
that
besides in
though you decided it was going to
happen it's all in the culvert of allah
and that it's a it's an idea that you
don't fully
need to understand as a muslim but it is
an idea that you need to believe in
and that it's it's not really like a
focal point that should make or break
you
that you you you decide what you do
every day and that no matter what you
already do
or have done all that was already in the
cult of allah and that's the meaning
yeah bro fletcher people take this as as
some
um i guess a little precursor to some
victim mentality
and we're not preaching that at all you
can't be like okay allah already wrote
it for me no
see i i got this from a zaka knight
video may allah
bless the the brother man his videos
change the world
and well that was part of the qatar of
allah so allah already knew that
but anyway that's neither here nor there
so the point i'm trying to get to
brothers and sisters is
we do have free will it's not that allah
is controlling us
it's allah made us allah allah created
us we are allah's creation no one else's
because he created us you know us he
knows us so intimately so deeply
he literally made us he willed for us to
exist because he created us
he gave us free will but time doesn't
exist
time transcends into seven heavens time
is a construct that man has created
to help us understand the trials and
tribulations of this dunya of the three
dimensions that we exist
in so even though allah gave us free
will
yeah we everything we do just like
fletcher picked up his phone and put it
down
he made those decisions but allah knows
him so well that allah knew that was
going to happen
so allah wrote that in the qatar it's
literally like this decree this
this whole um you know allah writing
down
everyone and what they're going to do
every action they take every thought
that goes through their heads whether
they go to heaven or hell
allah didn't assign them heavenly help
allah didn't
like make a program and do the coding
and then execute it
and run the application no allah created
you
and then exactly wrote down what was
gonna happen allah wrote down okay
there's gonna be three doors
you're gonna go through a b or c allah
didn't write down b
because he wants you to go through b
allah wrote down b because he gave you
free will and he knew you would choose
door b i'll also wrote down what would
happen if you didn't choose door b and
you chose door a
or c conversely vice versa and i think
that's amazing that's beautiful it's
about a lot
well that's like the example that i gave
you know
i want to say was it episode one or was
it episode two the video game example
can't remember bro to sum it up it's
like it's exactly what y'all are saying
but in a very simple and easy to grasp
uh analogy or an example
is uh you have a video game where
everything in the video game has already
been programmed
right if you come into the video game
and then there's like
there's two decisions you can make you
can kill this person or you can let them
live
right whatever choice you choose that's
your free will that's equivalent to free
will
but whatever is going to happen has
already been programmed so whether you
choose to let the person live
or whether you choose to kill the person
it's already been written
so like the ending of the game has
already been written but to you
it's unknown and your free will is just
like
the decision that you make in those
little moments
all right guys i think we're good to
wrap on this topic um
i've got i've got one more thing go for
it man go away so
i would say i i have a little i forgot
who i learned this from
and my love lesson of how to like
memorize the six
pillars of iman a really really simple
way to memorize six players because a
lot of people be like
you got a lot of books how many am i
you know i would say a good way to
memorize it and i love doing this is
allah sent the angels who brought the
books to the messengers
about the day of judgment and all of
this is the color of allah
it's a good easy way to memorize it and
i i
you don't have to follow my way but i
recommend it it's very easy
may allah bless you for sharing that um
romney i know do you guys have anything
to
uh say before we go on to our full
revert
guide say now i had one question
but it's all the way back about married
a while ago i said oh fletcher you said
something interesting i wanted to ask
about
it and then on how's question the fight
asked a question and then we got into
this beautiful discussion
i was going to ask you said if uh if
you're
able to support do you mean if you're
able to work make money have a house
and support yourself and your wife is
that what you mean or
do you mean in the sense that you're at
least trying and you have some kind of
income
because i've heard different opinions
and i don't know what's like in arkansas
uh our campuses i don't know what it's
like in arkansas
um but here in canada and where i live
specifically
you can't work a minimum wage job and
you know rent an apartment and support
yourself and just that the other
let alone two people oh my god don't get
me started yeah sorry
and yeah it is it is where you live
also makes a difference and
overall no matter what your decision is
is that you need to
put your faith and trust in a law no
matter what
um and that if you
if you if you are working a minimum wage
job and you want to
and you want to support a wife and you
want to support yourself
independently the number one thing to do
is to put your trust in allah
and that not to put your trust into the
means
like the means your funds that you were
making that you shouldn't be putting
your trust in the means that you know i
need to earn more money before
i do this and this and this i need to
have this much saved up before this in
this and that's
if you have enough even if it's the
minimum enough
that you should put your trust in the
law first
before put your trust in allah to
provide you the means
and i'd say that's the absolute most
important thing and that's what a lot of
the pious predecessors have done
uh i i take imam ahmed for example that
he
lived an extremely poor life his entire
life
and that he would travel
extreme distances on barely any money
and when he'd run out of money
he'd still have that trust in allah to
go find a job just to get him to his
destination
i mean subhanallah just to show that we
we have this mentality that i need to
save up
all of this money first before i do
anything
you're talking about the prophet saws no
it's talking about imam ahmed rahim
allah
okay
is your thing relevant to this it's very
relevant all right man i'm gonna let you
go
thanks thanks bro exactly what you said
man
i actually had an experience first hand
and this is before i became muslim
all right it was this summer i was um i
was about to get my surgery so i
scheduled surgery and it's in new york
i live in florida you know how crazy
covert is
you know how crazy it is well they like
doing random lockdowns and all this
stuff
well bro i had to get my copy results
um a week before my actual surgery
day all right so i got my kobe results
and there was an
issue where the results actually didn't
come in in time so
i was like you know what i'm just gonna
go anyway so i'm
leaving to new york i get to the second
uh it was a connecting flight
all right so we get to the second part
it's just me by myself
and i'm over here thinking like damn
dude like i don't have my
my test results my surgeries tomorrow
like if i don't get my test results and
i can't have my surgery
i'm gonna be staying at this airbnb like
i don't i don't know if i'm gonna have
the funds to be able to like
push it and like stay at the airbnb even
longer
bro and wallahi well bro
this dude that i knew from high school
showed up out of nowhere he was like
bro i was like no bro i met him again
and we went to new york i stayed at his
place
so subhanallah bro i didn't have to pay
for the airbnb in the meantime
in the meantime while i was getting my
test results and then look how crazy
this is right
they were saying that um there was going
to be a lockdown or there was going to
be a quarantine so if i would have to
get quarantined
then i would have had to wait two weeks
before i could get my surgery
and bro subhanallah the moment we got to
new york
literally i want to say like five or six
hours after that
that's when the quarantine started
so bro like everything happened like in
perfect timing
where it's like if i think back to that
there was no way
that i could have planned that and again
bro it's like i always say a lot
is the best the plan is bro
[Music]
i'm going on man
[Music]
what was your point that you were gonna
save i can't even remember
but it's all said and done we're good to
go let's proceed
now for any of you wondering all right
i'm kind of on board with islam kind of
not if you're kind of not let me address
this point
very valid very important you are still
emotionally skeptical or you are afraid
of being ostracized
in society or you are afraid of being
disowned by maybe your family or you are
and these are real fears
and you are maybe afraid of um okay what
if i like
what if i'm not good enough to be a
muslim
so i want you to address any and all of
these points that you can
all of us insha allah as a team but
fletcher you got the mic for now
talk us through walk us through so you
got a guy who lived his whole life
not believing islam guy or girl and this
man or woman today
is right in front of us bro they've been
questioned they've experienced cognitive
dissonance
to the millionth degree as rami always
says
and they're finally coming to terms
they've calmed down and they're like
okay
islam is it i can deny it but my soul my
fitra
it's testifying for me on behalf of me
already so what do they do how do they
start
i would i would say that if they have
that
if they have that belief 100
you know and they don't want to fully
express it right away
um i think you could do is just
do it yourself uh you know testify that
there's no god blood muhammad is the
messenger of allah
um i me personally i went out into my
masjid and i publicly you know testified
that you know
and so i took a public shahada um but
not every person needs to do that
um and that if you if you still need
more proof or you're afraid of like what
if i convert
and then like i don't like it which i
highly doubt it
but like what if they if they have that
fear is you could do it yourself before
like try prostrating to allah try
try understanding the quran uh
try to try to submit yourself try to
like humble yourself to a point where
even in even a position like sajud and
just speak to allah
you know and then
i think at that point eventually people
will just
kind of give in and then become muslim
in a sense of belief that you know i
believe in allah
and that muhammad is the final messenger
of allah
see believing that is already makes you
muslim
ladies and gentlemen the shahada just
legitimized it's like it seals the deal
and as muslims
take it as you will but there's nothing
wrong with doing a shahadah yeah
you want that full conviction but your
conviction is not going to be
more times than not at the time of the
shahada anywhere near as it will be down
the line inshallah
so that's why we renew the shahadah guys
when you pray
every time you pray you say the shahada
so if it
wasn't valid yesterday let's believe if
you follow that form that conviction
today
it'll be valid today so every single day
you're affirming your shahada and your
oneness and belief in allah
so if not now then when if not
here then where it's wrong
it's final law uh if i may add to that
i do know a sister who
finally took her shahada and up until
that point she was so worried she was so
scared like
because if she lives in a christian
family uh actually she also lives in
florida
and she was so worried she's so
skeptical but she knew she wanted to
convert to islam she had dreams of her
in the masjid and all the stuff
subhanallah and she finally went to the
masjid beautiful place masha'allah
and she took the shahada and she was
crying it she was so happy and it was
the best
thing she said she's like she's ever
done and she was so happy she finally
did it i got a few messages from people
afterwards saying like
very similar things so it's kind of like
you have that emotional skepticism
before you step in the door and it might
seem scary but once you're on the other
side you're kind of like
i'm so happy i did that like have you
guys ever had one of those moments where
like
you want to do something you're not too
sure and it's kind of like a shot in the
dark for you at the time and then you do
it and you're like what was i so worried
about
and then you're so happy that you did it
yeah like i feel like everybody has that
but
it's like that to the highest degree
it's like
you're scared for no reason and the only
reason you're scared is because
emotional reasons the people on the
outside and has nothing to do with the
creator has nothing to do with on the in
what's on the inside it's just external
factors that are
worrying you so i would say if you have
emotional worries
then take a logical irrational approach
to it
right nobody's ever scared that one plus
one might equal five
they know that one plus one equals two
and that's the end of it
so you have emotional skepticism
back it up or refute it with any logical
rational reasoning and if you can't find
that then you're just gonna know that
okay
anyone who comes to me is going to be
emotional and that doesn't really have
any standing right
at the end of the day yeah i mean you're
relying on emotion
people already know sometimes they're
tripping on emotion sometimes they feel
some type of way and then it subsides
why are you using this as your guiding
compass let me give you guys some tough
love before fletcher comes in
and angel comes in and then gives you
guys like a more like
warmer approach to like how to deal with
like family and all that
because they've actually gone through it
firsthand what if i get ostracized by
family what if society doesn't take it
the right way
and the tough life i'm gonna give you is
you guys
already believe in allah you guys
already believe in
islam in the quran and instead of
fearing allah you're fearing society
you're fearing his creation you're
fearing the dunya
you're looking for all these guarantees
of the dunya
instead of just trusting that allah has
already ordained that you have nothing
guaranteed in this dunya except death
so what are you waiting for that's a
that's an excellent point
and to talk about family i won't be
using me as an example because
alhamdulillah i've had an extremely easy
experience coming into islam
whether it's family and friends all my
friends i'm not very accepting about
what guide them
um my wife
for example she is also a revert to
reversal
she she grew up in a catholic household
a very straight catholic household and
her transition to islam telling them
about stem
is a lot more difficult than mine and i
would
i would say that she would tell you that
that she she kept putting off her
shahada because she had for a long long
time she knew that she wanted to be
muslim
and then she kept putting off her
shahada until just one day
it kind of happened when she was just
going to ask questions
at a masjid it just kind of happened and
that after that day she
she she told me that this is like that
was the best
moment ever that i should have done it
sooner that
uh you know there was no reason to be
scared of
and that you know because after that
moment you you do
feel a sudden rush of belief
and absolute oneness on the law that's
i have nothing to worry about anymore
you know i'm muslim
what fight is going to be like that's
confirmation bias but not man
absolutely
and all i gotta say is that it's between
the creator and you
is it not between anyone else yeah
and you know to bring whatever y'all
said into the equation
like you shouldn't fear what anyone else
thinks
you shouldn't feel what anyone else says
that you should fear
the creator because the creator is the
one that has
the last say in everything like at the
end when you die
like your parents aren't gonna bring you
back to life
your friends aren't gonna bring you back
to life like yes
alhamdulillah your parents brought you
into this world but that was by
the grace of god that was
that was god like that wasn't your
parents your parents didn't like
construct you and like make you
they just did the natural obligation and
then allah did the rest
yeah it was like bro at the end of the
day it's it's you
and the creator and if you're feeling
something if you
feel the pull best believe it's not for
nothing
because a lot of guys
we lose just uh just to pick it
up i mean quickly uh i had two points
really quickly when i make
on that point of like worrying about
what other people say just think about
it like this on the day of judgement
you you're not allowed to go to allah
and say yeah but they said this and this
and that and then i just listen to them
about people on the day of judgement
that will say why don't we see the
people who we consider the lowest of the
low
down here in hell with us what like
where are they like are they not in here
or like are we just missing them
were we wrong and saying what we said
about them in this life
and then they'll say to allah and the
angels
the chiefs the people who had power over
us that told us do this and do that and
and oh you know obey us and worship the
idols
double the punishment on them for
bringing us down here with them
it was still their choice to follow them
and they knew that they had no way out
double the punishment on them you don't
want to be the person that the
punishment is doubled upon you don't
want to be the person that followed the
wrong people
and who got punished for it so on the
day of judgment you're not allowed to go
to allah and say well i mean this person
said this and i didn't want to be you
know
alienated that's my first point the
second point if i can remember
no i'll set my mind man add that to the
list of how many times i said that
but uh yeah i mean man when it's all
said and done
it's only you and allah yeah absolutely
surprisingly
no one else and it's like bro i was
talking on her about this um
you know in his journey to islam that a
lot of people delay the shahada and it's
like
bro nothing is guaranteed you can leave
your house
god forbid something could happen just
like fletcher said
yeah it might be your last prayer you
might even not make it through your
prayer
no one knows what's going to happen so
there's no point delaying something
especially when it's not
something that contrary to preconceived
beliefs
it's not like okay you go on you go on
the news and you
testify and then everyone sees you nah
bro you could do it in your room
you could do it in your bed just
reciting the shahada so
let you get into that what is the
shahada what is the transliteration
what is the translation um why
is it sufficient enough to make you a
muslim any of you guys can
hop in on this too um
once that's done you're muslim you're
you know everything's done everything's
fine and dandy but what can you do from
this point on
yeah so the shahada in general
we know it's one of the five pillars of
islam
the shahadah to testify that there's no
god but allah there's no
there's no deity worthy of worship other
than allah
and that muhammad is his slave
and messenger of allah which he goes
it's it's a very powerful statement that
kind of gave me chills right now just
kind of
reciting it to be honest um
it's and that's really all you need to
be a muslim is to say that with full
conviction
and during my journey to islam
the night that we scheduled to do my
shahada
at the masjid during around montreal
time i think
and then before that happened in my
house i was extremely nervous
just about showing up to them i
shouldn't doing this whole thing and
then in my bed i was
looking at my phone looking at the
shahada like online like how to
pronounce it and just going to show them
one night
mainly because i thought i had to
memorize it before i got there but on
the other hand i just wanted to just
get it in me before i kind of like
officially did it
and it it was very powerful and it was
soothing
even though i was extremely nervous
about this beautiful thing
just to
it's a very beautiful statement and i'm
sure i'm god
can can put more into that
so just before all now goes the
translation transliteration how do you
feel that
the power behind that i know it's a
feeling you can't really understand why
we feel that but
why do you think there's such
significance to that to what's being
said
yeah i when you translate it
it's it's such a such a it's a hard
translation
but the english kind of does a good job
to explain it overall
but the arabic the ash
that there is absolutely without a doubt
no deity worthy of worship besides allah
it shows the power of allah himself to
show that
this creator this this
this this god our god the one and only
god
is in absolute control of everything
and deserves absolute and maximum
worship upon all of us
uh and to say well ash
shows again like i
would say the humility of our prophet
muhammad saw
and the importance of him in our
religion to say
and the final slave and messenger of
allah is muhammad saw said
to show that he is a slave of allah to
show that even he himself the most
perfect human being submits himself to
this creator
that me myself am now doing when
testifying this shahadah
simultaneously why while emphasizing the
importance
and the utmost severity of how without
him we would not have islam
that's right but people get that twisted
in the in the picture somehow that we
worship muhammad
rasulullah or we we praise him
nah we we don't prostrate to him do we
respect him yeah we have sunnah we have
sunnah prayers we respect him more than
either human being
let's get that straight so we will
defend him but at the same time
we don't worship him we don't prostrate
him we don't bow down to him he's still
a human being
just like just like he said he is a
slave and messenger of god
but what's the second part he's a
messenger of allah the final messenger
of allah
without him there would be nothing there
would be no islam
and that that's an important point
there's a hadith
um the prophet saws that says like none
of you who will have
none of you will truly perfect your
faith until he loves me
but also i said him more than anyone and
everyone
including yourself in this this powerful
statement
who overheard this statement and he
turned around to the messenger of allah
and said
i love you more than my family i love
you more than all my wealth i love you
more than everything
but i'll be honest i don't love you more
than myself that's just one thing you
cannot do
it's hard to love someone more than
yourself because it's the natural love
that you have
but he heard the rule 67 respond to him
and say then you have not truly
perfected your faith
in our he turned around and he
contemplated the state this statement
and the necessity ahmad really
understood the necessity of
loving rasulallah and this isn't a
this isn't a love that turns into a
worship this is a love that
is love for someone just as you love
your mother or your father
and that he finally turned back around
and said yeah rasool allah now i love
you
and now you have truly apologize your
face
and that he understood this as an
intellectual love
a necessity to love him but not to
worship him
and so on allah
i don't even know what to add to that
bro
beautiful answer you could
tie off on a second point which was
you've done the shahada maybe you've
said it
right now during this very video
subhanallah if you have
no pressure if you haven't reach out to
us um
stay tuned figure out how sort some
things out but
we'll put it down in the description
regardless in english transliteration
any of y'all that want to take that step
forward and get your life right
inshaallah but with that being said on
how
once they do what are the next steps do
you just take the shahada and be like
okay bet
i'm gonna be saved on the last day
because there might be
because it's like it's like that one
thing says um
please one of y'all chime in and say
like where it's from
even what suit um what was quoted but it
says that
do you think that you would believe and
not be tested
where's that from i the only one i know
of you may be referring to a different
verse but in surah al-imran allah says
do you think that you will be
yeah do you think you'll be granted
jannah um while you have not been tested
i believe that was the verse
so if someone says okay
or not but they they do the the shahadah
right
best believe you're going to be tested
in one way shape or form if you take a
step back and just pay attention
you're going to be tested either by the
way other people perceive you
either by things that are going on in
your life either by your own
thoughts you are going to be tested and
it's up to you now to read
and to begin to take those baby steps
forward and
to learn how to recite you know learn
the quran
and go from there and the the biggest
advice i give you know
i'm i'm still a baby to this bro like
fletch is over here
two years deep bro mashallah i'm over
here like two months deep
so bro like the biggest advice i have is
literally baby steps because
there's so much that there's so much and
like you said
right now you're studying what did you
say you were studying again
the the seerah the life of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
and you said that you may never even
complete your studies
in a lifetime right that it that right
there should let you know that you
should not try to take on everything at
once
and if you do you will burn out and if
you burn out
there's a high chance that you're either
going to
sin and you're going to sin consciously
you're going to know you're sinning
you're still going to do it because
you're just burned out you have
no control over anything or two
you just going to let it all go and
you're probably going to become like one
of these ex-muslims and
probably get all emotional about certain
parts of the quran or certain things
where it's like ah well it doesn't make
sense
no it does make sense you just got
burned out
or you just got too emotional about it
so just take baby steps man
that's a great point not getting burned
out
and it's important for the muslim
community
that when a person takes their shahada
the muslim community has an obligation
upon them to teach them
and to advise them the prophet said
when when the sahaba first converted to
a saddam
he taught them how to pray and that was
the first thing that's what every
sahabah did first
was learn how to pray their soul learn
when to pray what to say
what are the emotions and what do they
mean more importantly what does
salah mean and what are you saying
during your salah that these are the
most important things
and that our muslim community needs to
be the people that step up
and help the riverts and
the converts understand their sola
and go forward with
their research of the dean itself
bro i would go on a hat as well that
when people are trying to learn
the recitations and and like i said i'm
still a baby to this i'm so very new
i'm i'm at the very end here where i'm
learning the
tashahud and like at first like looking
at it i was like yo this is tough
like this is rough but like now i'm
listening to it and it's like in my mind
it's playing out like yeah it may not be
perfect but it's playing out in my mind
and like the thing that i want to you
know give to people who are reverses
like
do the baby steps and if you truly
if you're truly truly interested have
fun with it
just get into it and you'll see how
allah will make it easy for you
and you you'll start to recite it in
your head like you'll start to sing it
as if it was a song and like
something where it's like let's say i
were to play you a random song like
maybe it might take you an entire day to
be able to
memorize what's being said maybe it
might take you two three four days
oh if you are truly having fun with it
and you're learning these uh recitations
you hear once
over you're playing in your head in a
matter of an hour you'll probably have
the recitation
100 that's that's a beautiful thing
about it man
the power of recall bro
and for the final point before we wrap
this up ladies and gentlemen
what if i'm not good enough what if i've
lived a life
full of sin how did i know okay these
are sins and these are not sins
i've done a lot of sins what do i do am
i good enough could i revert to a son
um am i going to be accounted for my
previous sins what if i could
what if i continue them yeah i was
ignorant but a lot forgive me
what are your thoughts educate them
go ahead you go first
knows the condition of a person in which
he put them in
and allah says in surah surah in the
very last verse
allah does not burden the soul beyond
that which you can bear
so if you are a person who is entering
islam you better know that allah is not
going to overburden you with something
you can't handle
and allah does not expect you to okay
now muslim i need to
instantly know how to pray magically
that doesn't make sense and allah knows
that allah knows everybody's situation
and as we talked about even the sahaba
they had a more
allah took a more gradualistic approach
with them where
they started with the foundation and
built over time and then the haram
and halal were made here and there and
here and there
but it wasn't just okay now you guys
have to be like amazing
and as for the sins of the past allah
the prophet
who was a man who we talked about in the
last episode
he was a man who was a military
strategist and he worked against prosper
he
almost he almost he killed most i think
or
a lot of the muslims in bothered like
his strategy is what caused the downfall
of that battle for the muslims uh
inevitably
and he killed you know it what he did
caused hamza to die musabinum
and many other sahaba and it was a
devastating day for the muslims
and that's actually when allah revealed
the verses um
i believe uh in surah al-imran that i
was i quoted
and very beautiful if you guys you know
listen to it and khalid bin waleed
already along with he went to the
falsehood
he's ready to convert but he said before
i do just ask allah to forgive me
for everything i did in the past and the
prophet said don't you know that
every single time a person accepts islam
for the first time he comes into islam
allah forgives them for everything they
did in jahidiyah when
when they were jahilas as angel says in
the past in ignorance
and he said still still ask allah to
forgive me
so the prophet is telling us to anybody
who accepts islam
will be forgiven for everything in the
past they did pre-islam
and i think this is a guarantee yes it
is a promise
alhamdulillah i want to make one thing
uh clear i do have to go unfortunately i
know we're going to wrap it up
insha'allah fletcher
can say the masala in this one
but um in surah 29 verse 2 allah says do
you think
uh once they say we believe that they
will be left without being put to the
test that is the verse that angel
quoted the one i quote in
it says do you think you will be given
paradise while allah has not made
made evidence those who fight in his
cause and those who are steadfast upon
the deen
um with that being said unfortunately i
do have to go may allah bless you all
jesus
let you for coming on may allah bless
you
alaikum warahmatullahi
he made an excellent point there saying
telling that story about khalid
because if you if you do look at the
life of previous to islam
uh it's it truly is
if we if we did not have this promise of
forgiveness the allah and you looked at
the life of quran
and what he had did especially to the
muslims
you would think that allah could never
forgive them but we have that beauty of
absolute 100 trust in allah's
forgiveness especially as a reaver
but there's no jesus died for your sins
not to throw [ __ ] on christianity but
there's no like
okay you know you can do whatever and
god won't judge and god will understand
nah
god will understand but god judges
because he understands
and he understands why you do what you
do why you sin
why you do good deeds and as i believe
everything you do will come back to you
if you do a lot of good
oh allah is going to give you that times
whatever if you do
not so good allah is going to make that
definitely you're going to be punished
like
it's equilibrium it's law of
thermodynamics it's justice as rami says
we can't be doing vile things in this in
this life in this dunya
like a lot of bad people like hitler and
um you know a lot of people that are you
know
slaying muslims slaying christians
slaying human beings in general for no
reason
and you can't and let's talk about that
people die
without getting punished they live a bad
life
they kill people they steal they do
whatever
they ruin lives they spread falsehood
about islam and whatever
and they got no punishment and they die
you really think that's it do you really
think they got away that easily
and vice versa some kid who's growing up
in innocent life
didn't know what was coming got killed
for no reason
and do you really think that's it like
it just ends like that yeah it makes no
sense
and this is not just a belief but it
genuinely makes no sense
that's probably that's an excellent
point
just like a low credit do you guys have
anything else that you want to bring up
before we wrap this podcast
um yeah the last thing that i want to
say
is that you are forgiven
but you should not forget
meaning that you are forgiven for your
sins but you should not forget
the sins you've done because you learn
from those sins you understand what i'm
saying
or it's like if you sing but then you
forgot
about it and then you just have no
recollection of it you have no
um you didn't learn from it you know
what i'm saying
then there's a high chance that it may
happen again because we are imperfect
awareness is key consciousness is key
mm-hmm
all right guys thank you so much for
watching
another episode of the t3m podcast i
could say that with confidence because
it we are in fact currently t3m
because we're back to three without rami
but rami has work
anyway salaamwalekum
fletcher thank you so much for joining
us in this in this conversation
so much productivity value and
spreading the deen if people want to get
more of you if people want to reach out
and hit you up where can they find
yourself you can find me on instagram
and twitter
um or my i also have a youtube channel
uh
i'll be sure to i'll be sure to send my
links over to you guys so you can just
put them down below we'll drop that
if you just look up fletcher phillips
you should be able to just find me
pretty much anywhere though
perfect all right guys that's it
you want to close it out for us what's
it all sure i'll close it out
what did i just say just some ammo
uh say a little bit what does romney say
[Music]
i don't know i forgot i guess i'll just
go
yeah just makes a dua okay may allah
bless you all may allah
allow the people who are seeking islam
to fully gain the confidence to take the
shahada
may allah allow the reverts and the born
muslims to
strive in this deen and learn their
religion and gain that
confidence and allah and his messenger
may allah blah may allah bless you you
two brothers and romney
uh for the work you're doing and may
allah keep you guys steadfast on your
deen
and the work you're doing for the um i
mean
i mean brother we will have you again
inshallah on this position
i can't wait all right guys until next
time